is the new M3 MacBook Pro worth it over
the 13-in MacBook Air with the M2 Chip
because right now you can buy this thing
on Amazon for
$1,050 compared to ,600 on this M3
MacBook Pro that's
$5 more which is a lot so in this video
I'm going to compare everything
including the specs displays the
keyboards connectivity ports performance
and more and I promise by the end of
this video You're you're going to know
which one is more worth it to buy now
starting off I do want to mention that
this M3 MacBook Pro now does come with a
512 GB SSD compared to 256 gigs on the
MacBook Air now when we tore down this
machine we did notice that apple is now
putting two nand chips finally once
again compared to only one man chip on
the MacBook Air and that's going to
impact the performance of the SSD D
which I'll show you in a minute but
first let's get into comparing the
actual designs as you guys can see we
have the midnight color on the MacBook
Air which looks really cool but you
probably notice a bunch of these
fingerprints and I intentionally left
this on because they're always there in
regular use the fingerprints are always
showing up against this dark blue finish
so I didn't want to clean it off and
make it look perfect this is what you're
going to see compared to Silver on the
new M3 MacBook Pro and you you can see
that the footprint is very similar but
this one is definitely a little bit
bigger as you can tell on all sides it
sticks out just a little bit more but
it's not that big of a deal now in terms
of the thickness that's where it gets
crazy because take a look at that side
by side you can see just how much
thicker the MacBook Pro is compared to
that MacBook Air this thing feels
amazing it's so lightweight in your
hands it just feels almost impossible to
pack this much performance and
everything into such a thin laptop of
course this MacBook Pro is definitely
heavier but I think it's worth it for
the performance which you'll see in a
minute now in terms of the ports the
base MacBook Pro finally gets the new
redesign so it gets Max sa 3 which is
awesome the same on the MacBook Air you
got two Thunderbolt ports and the
MacBook Pro gets the headphone jack here
on the left side now going over to the
other side the MacBook Air has the
headphone jack on that side while the
MacBook Pro actually gets HDMI and an SD
card slot which is incredible it's so
convenient to have both of those ports a
big step up from the MacBook now I know
you're probably wondering about the
15-in MacBook here so I have it right
here just to show you guys kind of the
difference in footprint so as you can
see on that top cam take a look look at
that the 15in definitely bigger all the
way around in terms of the footprint and
in terms of the thickness the 15in is a
little bit thicker than the 13 but still
quite a lot thicker than that 14-in
MacBook Pro and of course on the inside
the MacBook Pro does get a single fan
with a heat sink and heat pipe while
both of the MacBook airs are fanless and
you're probably also wondering about the
difference in screen size so here you go
I set them all up the 13-inch MacBook GE
you have a step up to that 14in and then
a pretty big step up for the 15in this
actually gets quite a bit bigger than
you'd expect just going one more inch up
so here's the difference in the screen
real estate and other than that there's
really no differences between the 13 and
15-in MacBook Air so I'm going to put
this away and now getting into the
keyboards and the trackpads they have
basically the same keys but the
difference is the MacBook Pro does have
the black kind of anodized metal behind
it which looks really cool and contrasts
well with the silver while this kind of
looks similar with the midnight and the
black now you might notice that the
MacBook Pro has speaker grills right
here so they fire up compared to the
MacBook Air that does not it actually
fires through this hinge and reflects
back now actually on the MacBook Pro you
do have these little vents which are for
the down firing woofers so this should
sound quite nice so let's actually
compare the speakers right now and by
the way the trackpads are basically
identical but first our sponsor software
keep is having a massive 111 day sale on
genuine Microsoft software and all
combos Like Home Office for Mac plus PDF
Reader Pro they've got over 100,000
five-star reviews and great 24/7 365
customer support so use the links in the
description below with coupon code MX
tech25 for 25% off sitewide to World of
silver no more heart breaks tears
painkiller take me somewhere on familiar
bring me back to where we
[Music]
started me out
of holy smokes guys did you just hear
that this thing as soon as it turned on
I was blown away once again even though
I've heard this many times wow it is
just so much better in every single way
this thing is basically all about mids
and highs the bass is gone the
separation of frequencies The Sound
Stage is gone this compared to that is
just absolutely amazing and now let's
get into the display quality comparison
as you can see they both have the same
sized Notch but it does look a little
bit smaller on the 14inch just because
the screen is bigger but in terms of
quality there is a huge difference
because this year the base MacBook Pro
finally adopts the high-end mini LED
display from the more expensive machine
so you have up to 1,600 nits of
brightness for HDR content which looks
absolutely amazing compared to the
regular LCD panel on the MacBook Air
that's limited to 500 at all times and
the bonus with this new machine is that
they've set the standard brightness to
600 nits so it's a little bit brighter
for all situations not just the HDR and
another huge benefit for the MacBook Pro
is that it has promotion 120 HZ display
refresh rate Tech that can go between 24
and 120 based on what you're viewing
like if you're watching a 24 HZ movie
then it's going to go down to that and
save battery life while the MacBook Air
is always limited to 60 it can't go down
can't go up and that kind of sucks
especially for gaming which is why I
always choose the pro motion displays
and now let's get into the webcams and
the microphones this is the 1080p webcam
on the MacBook Air so let's see how it
sounds and Compares and then this is on
the M3 MacBook Pro let me know if you
hear any differences in the microphones
or if you see any differences on the
camera I almost maybe even see a little
bit more noise in my face but you let me
know down in the comment section below
and now let's get right into the
performance comparison starting with
geek bench 6 which is a very simple
Benchmark which gives you the general
performance performance of both machines
first of all we do have 8 gigs of RAM
based on both of these and I do want to
mention that 8 gigs is probably not
enough if you actually do care about
performance and you do productivity work
at least once a week in that case you
probably want 16 and we proved it in
this video right there which you can
definitely watch after this one ends a
really big deal between the 8 and 16 but
getting back to this we have the M2 2 on
this MacBook Air that goes up to 3.48
GHz while the M3 goes up to
4.05 so let's run a CPU Benchmark for
single core performance the M3 is about
19% faster and for multicore the M3 is
about
212% faster moving on to the graphic
side of performance the M2 Chip comes
bin with an 8 core GPU while the M3 has
a 10 cord and it looks like the M3 with
the 10 cord is about 22% faster in RAW
graphics performance and now to test out
the real world performance of web
browsing and web-based apps I have this
project in figma from our favorite
Design Studio 500 designs based out of
California who makes great websites and
the first test I'm going to do is
basically rapidly zooming in and seeing
how long it takes to kind of load up
this image there you go it just loaded
and now let's do the same over on on
this one and it looks like wait it's
almost like it already loaded much more
quickly that's interesting and now the
second part of this test is to actually
export 12 of these different web pages
or layers at four times resolution pngs
so let's test this out and see which one
finishes first and it looks like the M3
MacBook Pro finished in a minute and 36
seconds compared to a minute and 52 on
the MacBook Air so realistically it is
faster but it's not a GameChanger unless
you're doing this all day and I almost
forgot that we've got to test and
compare the SSD transfer speed so I have
Blackmagic design speed test let's run
it we have 256 gig here compared to
512 wow in terms of the read speed the
M3 MacBook Pro with the 512 is almost
twice as fast and right speed is over
twice as fast the main reason for this
is the single n on the MacBook Air
that's basically losing half of the
channels because that slot is empty
while the MacBook Pro is populating both
nand chips and increasing the speed and
now let's actually do a gaming Benchmark
this is 3D Marks Wildlife extreme
unlimited this is going to show you the
real world gaming performance of each
machine wow the M3 is 41% faster in
terms of FPS even though the actual RAW
graphics difference wasn't that big in
geekbench it's probably because there's
extra GPU features that this is
utilizing so this is a huge boost for
gaming performance and now I'm really
excited to test out the thermal
throttling because this thing does not
have a fan while the M3 MacBook Pro does
but first I want to do a couple of very
fun tests that you guys have been
requesting music production with logic
pro right here and of course xcode right
after this so this is basically a stress
test seeing the maximum load in terms of
tracks that the C you can handle before
overloading so let's go ahead and see
how much we can
do all right I just did some testing and
it looks like we've landed on these
scores right here the MacBook Air can
run 80 tracks at the same time without
overloading while the MacBook Pro with
the M3 can do
116 so definitely a nice improvement
from the M2 to the M3 and now we have
the xcode Benchmark created for us by
Maxim arenco and I do want to mention
that xcode 15 is new so he had to
completely redesign the entire test make
it harder so all of the old scores are
no longer compatible so let's test it
out and there you go it's done it looks
like it took 142 seconds to finish on
the M3 MacBook Pro compared to
176 on the air so you are getting a nice
Improvement for programming especially
if you're doing it every day this is
definitely the better option and now we
have cine bench this is the 2024 version
which is a lot tougher on these systems
I'm going to be running a 10minute
stress test and looking at the wattages
and everything to see how much thermal
throttling there is I've just started
both of them and as you can see the
power spiked on both I think that hit 20
watts this thing is now ramping up we
can instantly see that the air is
limited to 3.2 GHz clock speed for the
PE cor while this is going at
3.64 that's a huge huge increase already
we could see the MacBook Air at 101
104° C right there is the hottest core
looking over at the MacBook Pro it's
still under 100 right now and 108 that
is the actual maximum limit that Apple
will allow these chips to hit before it
throttles down the power to basically
thermal throttle officially yes it's
ther Thal throttling right now because
you can see those cores are slowing down
right there no longer maxed out at 3.2
and right away take a look at the power
the power is coming down from 20 now
it's 17 it's throttling the wattage well
look at that the M3 still going strong
at about 19 20 watts no problems at all
and oh my goodness the MacBook Air keeps
throttling down to
3.0 gigahertz about to go under there
you go just went under it's throttling
like crazy and of course over here we
can see that the fans are ramping up
about halfway compared to the maximum
6800 RPMs the fans are kicking in now
the temps are in check staying lower
than the MacBook ear 101° C still hot
but it's pushing it to the Limit it's
been about 5 minutes and man this
MacBook Air keeps clocking down almost
13 watts of package power so I want to
actually test the temperatures of the
surfaces of these laptops to see what is
going on look at that we're looking at
44° C on the MacBook AA you just have a
big hot spot right there no fans so it
has to contain the heat through the
basic thermal transfer of the heat
Sinker or whatever is going on compared
to the MacBook Pro look at that the
Hotpot is only
34° celius holy moly that's a massive
difference 10° C difference and look at
that it's actually a hotter right there
where the single fan is pushing out
through the hinge area up to 40° this
thing is getting rid of heat this is
what it's supposed to do it's keeping
the chassis nice and cold compared to
dang look at that the test is done and
holy moly the M3 MacBook Pro is 45%
faster than the M2 that's due to all of
the thermal throttling because in
geekbench it was only about
21.5% faster in multicore now now it's
45 because of that fan and now let's get
into testing photo editing with
Lightroom classic we're going to export
50 raw 42 megapixel photos and Bam the
M3 MacBook Pro finished in a minute and
47 seconds compared to 2 minutes and
22 seconds on the MacBook Air that's
likely because of that nand chip that's
limiting the swap performance because
this test relies a lot on the RAM and if
you max out the 8 gigs it's going to use
the Swap and it's slower when you only
have one nchip and now getting into
basic video editing with Final Cut Pro
this is a 5 minute 4K H EVC project
which is by far the most common format
that most people are going to be editing
so let's see if there's any differences
in terms of exporting performance
because they both play back just fine 24
FPS no issues at all the exporting is
done it it looks like they're almost
exactly the same 2 minutes 20 seconds
for the M3 221 for the M2 MacBook Air
and that's because they essentially have
the same encoders as before for hvbc so
there's no difference for common basic
4K editing unless you're going to be
adding tons of effects then the M3 will
probably pull the lead and now let's get
into blender 3D rendering this is the
party tug project and I want to start
off with just a simple render image
using the EV engine which is actually
supporting R tracing on these machines
at least the M3 is what I mean because
this is the blender 4.0 beta and there
you go 7 and 1/2 seconds for the M3
compared to 11 1/2 on the M2 that might
not seem like a big difference but when
you have massive projects that is going
to be saving you a lot of time and there
you guys go that was a lot of
performance testing and testing in
general so let's answer answer the
original question of if it's worth
spending
$550 more for the M3 MacBook Pro well
first of all I do want to check the
battery life because I started both of
these at 100% battery on each we have 76
on the MacBook Air which is good and wo
79% on the MacBook Pro now in terms of
the general design the features the
MacBook Pro is definitely a winner even
though it's thicker slightly bigger
those extra ports the extra connectivity
is just so much better the display the
speakers the overall package is
definitely a win especially performance
if you're actually doing productivity
work or giving a big workload which the
fan is going to help you out a lot it's
definitely worth it but here is my
honest opinion if you're a casual user
that mostly just browses the web you
mostly just do business related work
school work home homework studying that
kind of thing with occasionally a video
edit or a photo edit you're going to be
just fine with this MacBook Air
especially saving
$550 I definitely recommend this thing
for the price now if you do care about
performance and you do care about all of
the new design the features the ports
the display features like promotion and
the performance and everything else then
this thing is a win even if you have to
spend that much more money especially if
you're buying it for business with a tax
write off and if you've got 1,600 to
spend definitely buy this over the
MacBook Air so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did
subscribe above and check out that 8 gig
ver 16 gig ram comparison video right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next
[Music]
video